marshall islands uh countries
pleading with the developed world to
step up to the plate and supply the
finance needed to make the changes
necessary to to fight climate change in
the developing world and we heard from
some of the the the of the
industrialized countries and developed
the developed world countries that
the faint signs of progress and i'd i'd
single out what we heard from uh from
denmark from from sweden from uh maybe
from italy uh and let's see what the
what the president has to say president
united states has to say tomorrow but
this is absolutely crucial because
the uh it's it's the it's the developing
world that are bearing this was the
point that was made so powerfully uh by
leader after leader uh it is the
developing world that is bearing the
brunt of catastrophic climate change in
the form of of hurricanes and uh and
fires and and floods
and the real long-term economic damage
that they face and yet it's it's the
developed world that over 200 years has
put the carbon in the atmosphere that is
causing this acceleration of climate
change and so it really is up to us uh
to help them and uh
anyway the arguments were made very
powerfully we'll have to see uh we have
to see where we get to in in securing
that 100 billion uh we also as you know
got some uh some good news about uh uk
travelers to
uh the uh
to the united states uh double
vaccinated uk travelers will be able to
go uh by uh by the end of uh by the end
of october
we're very used to global leaders
gathering annually to talk about climate
change
but we've also this year seen fast hand
the dangers of global warming with
terrible floods and fires across the
continents
are we now at an inflection point
i think that i think that glasgow cop 26
is a turning point for
the world and it's it's the moment when
we have to to grow up and take our
responsibilities i think we go through
uh you know a period of
of of glorious uh indifference about the
world we've been through that we've been
through our childhood if you like uh we
now got to realize that uh this is uh
this is a problem that requires uh grip
and and there are changes we're going to
have to make but people should be
optimistic because we can make these
changes uh whilst encouraging the
creation of literally millions of
high-wage high-skill jobs we need to
move from old
hydrocarbon technology into new clean
green technology and that is
fantastically promising and as you can
see with the current problems with some
of the hydrocarbon shortages in in
around the world caused by the the
resurgence of the global economy uh
we need more than ever to move to
security of supply uh for clean green
sources of energy